ça y est c'est toujours pareil chaque
fois que j'attends du courrier le
facteur est en retard à lille devrait
être là depuis longtemps j'ai vu casimir
c'est vrai il a l'air très énervé
semaine j'avais pas remarqué quand il
est comme ça c'est qu'il attend le
facteur tu crois mais ne reçoit jamais
de lettres à dire je le connais tu sais
tu regardes le bien qu est ce qu il est
en visite les frasques il marmonne pour
lui tout seul regard fréquents dans la
direction du chemin qui mène jusqu'au
port quand il est comme ça c'est qu'il
attend quelqu'un avec beaucoup
d'impatience et peut-être s'arrête
bonjour casimir regini j'ai gagné bravo
tu feras un merveilleux détective à l'or
olympique
oui elle a été déposé à la poste il ya à
peine cinq minutes et j'ai voulu que la
porte est aussitôt un a alors donné un
mois vit ce qu'il faut arriver à la
sortie mais on sait que pour une grosse
enveloppe
c'est une grosse [ __ ] paraît sur
bombay je te laisse aller à tout à
l'heure que j'ai mis au jour françois
gelez chat il céder une seconde
oui nous voudrions savoir c'est que
casimir attendait avec tant d'impatience
comment vous n'êtes pas au courant il ne
nous a rien dit pourtant c'est pas un
secret
casimir va se faire construire une
petite maison le bon ça leur prend la
dernière fois il avait voulu faire son
projet lui même avait donné une maison
vous avez raison et c'est pourquoi il a
demandé à l'architecte de lui fournir un
nouveau projet il lui avait promis pour
aujourd'hui
les créateurs pourquoi at il autant de
croo encore une drôle d'idée de notre
bon casimir quelle idée figurez-vous
qu'il voulait une maison mais alors
tellement original il a demandé des
dessins de monuments célèbres ou des
types d'horizons les plus répandus mais
cela uniquement faut être sûr qu'on ne
le vendrai pas un vieux modèle vous avez
bien de la chance vous devez parce que
moi j'ai pas le temps il faut que j'y
aille
on ne va pas bientôt dit donc aux
émirats est-ce que ça ça te plait coin à
huy ont surtout la maison quand je vais
me faire construire
tu nous avais caché sa fin je voulais
vous faire une surprise à venir d'où
étaient jetés maison c'est justement ce
qui m'ennuie je ne sais plus lequel
parmi ces dessins et ma maison tu n'as
aucune idée aucune
c'est peut-être ça bon honnêtement quasi
ça m'étonnerait alors je ne sais plus
comme casimir on va demander aux enfants
nous aider car oui ça c'est une bonne
idée mais les enfants nés war casimir a
besoin de vos conseils
voilà des dessins avec des habitations
et des monuments des ennemis on ne
connaît pas leurs noms
on va l'aider il cherche quelle est sa
maison qu'est ce que c'est que ça les
enfants me disent c'est une cathédrale
et qu'elle cathédrale c'est notre dame
de paris se trouvent dans l'île de la
cité
elle a été construite et très longtemps
au deuxième siècle et elle sert pour
toutes les grandes cérémonies c'est sa
quasi mirta désormais lancée par la
maison on a ça m'aurait étonné d'entre
nous qu'est ce que c'est que ça animals
à très grands immeubles c'est un
building y en a beaucoup dans le
quartier de la défense à côté de paris
est un des plus grands buildings du
monde s'appelle l' empire state building
c'est ta maison quasiment non c'est trop
grand pour moi c'est un don alors on va
voir une autre maison et chez eux
j'espère que nos amis chers
joli très bien katia c'est un château
fort c'était une demeure féodal
fortifiée alors gagne le tour donjon des
créneaux là et un pôle vie qui n'est pas
destinée d'ailleurs casimir annoncés
pour des boulots d'est c'est pas mal
mais c'est pas celle que j'ai choisie
c'est pas celle que tu as choisie ou
tiens voilà une qui est peut-être très
bien c'est un igloo
c'est fait avec les enfants s'asseoir
avec de la glace et dans quel pays et
qui habite la barre des eskimos c'est
très bien pour moi ça ne va pas parce
que d'une part il n'y a pas de glace sur
l'île aux enfants
et puis je n'ai pas de réfrigérateur
assez grand pour construire une maison
de danse et casimir qu'est ce que c'est
sa pyramide très bien une pyramide à
quoi ça servait olivier les pyramides
autrefois dans l'enseigné j -pd ça
servait comme grand temps pour les rois
ça servait de tombeaux on s'était dit
qu'on est la plus grande la plus haute
et des pyramides fait 138 m c'est
d'ailleurs la dernière des sept
merveilles du monde qui n'ait pas été
démoli
casimir n'y a pas cette fois m nokia
tombeau ce qu'un petit peu triste
ouais habiter un tombeau bon chez vous
vous cherchez un qu'est ce que c'est que
ça faire coter ce triomphe c'est l'arc
de triomphe lequel suit paris celui
paris parce que tu descends de triomphe
il y en a plusieurs
koné la hauteur on est bien et je fais
50 mètres de haut
il a été construit parquet sous les
ordres de qui
l'empereur de napoléon 1er
c'était pour commémorer ces victoires et
aux mayas des bas-reliefs très très
connu et notamment le plus célèbre de
tous et la marseillaise qui a été fait
par un sculpteur qui s'appelait rude
très connu tiens je lis bien mais on y
verra des courants d'air je voudrais pas
bien trop de courants d'air il ya
quelque chose c'est que j'ai oublié de
vous dire c'est qu'en dessous de l'arc
de triomphe
il y à la tombe du soldat inconnu est ce
que c'est que ça oh mais ça m'a l'air un
petit peu sur la scène travers à se
pencher ou est-ce que tout allait
construite en deux temps du sable ou
dans de la terre - très très bien ce que
tu dis elle s'appelle comment cette tour
c'est la tour de pise
salut se trouve prise tamise se trouve
en toscane en italie
casimir tu te vois moi confiance aux
jeunes architectes qui fait des choses
pareilles j'aurais trop peur
house est positivement petit à petit la
tour blanche de plus en plus ça va très
très très très long non évidemment mais
ça continue
alors est ce à casimir
ça se voit c'est dans une maison comme
simple qu'est-ce que ça les enfants
roaming si c'est en chine qu'on
contredit tout comme ça il ya des
réponses pour travailler que c'est un
film
oui c'est une église c'est une basilique
c'est une base in orthodoxe ce qui se
trouve pas en chine où sa caisse
moscou moscou en urss en ça s'appelle
saint basile le bienheureux chaque
coupole est différente et d'une couleur
différente
c'est magnifique c'est beau tu aimerais
invité là dedans les émirs ses citrons
luxueux pour l'udc ce qu'est ce que
c'est que ça évidemment la tour eiffel
est apparue en a pas deux dans le monde
quelle est la hauteur tu rappelé combien
fait dire 310 m oui oui c'est à peu près
ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est un
émetteur de télévision vous savez quand
on a construit la jurée fans à quelle
époque on la construit en 1900 pour
l'exposition de 1900 elle est au champ
de mars et à paris évidemment bon alors
2007 mano qu'est-ce qu'il ya maintenant
à ça c'est peut-être la maison casino
je la reconnais c'est celle là la maison
que je veux elle et elle est original
n'est-ce pas oui très original vous
loupé les enfants vous n'avez jamais vu
une maison si original vous avez là
bon j'en ai bien alors je n'en veux pas
l'epic qu'est ce qui t'arrive quasiment
pas parce que je ne veux pas d'une
maison que personne n'a jamais vu pour
être remarqué non non je vais prendre un
modèle beaucoup plus simple choisi est
un jeu répond celle là celle ci oui
fokehi mur c'est pas très sérieux ah non
mais attends je la ferai construire dans
ce sens là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]